Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in
chapter number 73
verses number
8 9 and 10.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
after commanding him to stand in prayer
specifically at night and this was the
first obligation of prayer in
Islamic legislation. He was to stand
in salah
in the nighttime recite the Quran at a
reasonable pace.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then mentions
the reasoning behind the nighttime as
opposed to the daytime and that is that
the nighttime
that it is more likely for the heart and
tongue to be aligned
and it is less likely for a person to
make mistakes in his recitation at night
due due to the lack of disturbance.
He says subhanahu
that in the daytime you have many chores
to tend to errands etc.
And so it becomes a less appropriate
time for this very intimate interaction
and meditation.
He then says in three verses here,
"And remember and recite the name of
your Lord and cut yourself off to him."
Now what's interesting about this verse
is that if we were to take this verse in
the context of what came before
which is standing in prayer recitation
reciting the Quran
then
here
is as many of the scholars of have
mentioned meaning that at the start of
your recitation you begin with
remember the name of your Lordis
in the context of recitation. How do we
remember the name of our Lord? Sayman
at the beginning of our recitation.
For this reason
it's mentioned that when a person
recites a chapter from its beginning
then a person says
in salah and outside of salah.
However, if a person recites a part of
the Quran
from the middle or the end anywhere
from after the first verse
in salah a person doesn't say
and the reason for that is that when we
begin our prayer and we begin recitation
of
when we say
this one time is sufficient for all of
the prayer. Just when we say
once at the beginning of the prayer and
we don't repeat it again.
However, outside of salah, if a person
wishes to read any part of the Quran,
not starting at the very first verse
of a chapter,
the correct opinion is that the person
has the
the choice to either begin his
recitation withman
or to say
and begin reciting.
This here
is with respect to recitation.
[Silence]
You for
lack.
[Silence]
And this is something that is common.
You hear people
that if a person for instance the and
the question here is there's a
difference between recitation of the
Quran and mention of the Quran. If a
person wishes to recite the Quran, these
rulings are what apply to that.
However, if a person merely wishes to
mention the Quran, mention a verse,
mention a cluster of verses to in a
lecture or in aba or in a talk or in his
teaching of his children or speaking
a person wishes to mention a verse from
the Quran. In this case, does a person
say
or does a person say
ahead of the verse that he wishes to
make mention of. The answer is no.
You'll never find this anywhere that
this is how the companions or the
prophet sallall.aii was used to speak.
And you hear this often
[Silence]
wasch.
So you hear this often. A person says
you know his person is speaking and then
they wish to mention a verse they say
as Allah said
after
or a person says
and then mentions a verse. You'll never
find a narration this ever.
Many many narrations in which the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
would mention a verse, mention a cluster
of verses and he would not say
nor would he say
at the beginning before mentioning a
verse.
Likewise,
You call it
you read.
[Silence]
for
and so reciting
as a person mentions a verse. This also
is something that we wouldn't have any
evidence for in the Quran and Sunnah.
Rather the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he would go to mention a
verse whether he's given a or speaking
and he would say you know as Allah says
in such and such verse he wouldn't
recite it as he would in prayer he would
just say the verse as it is. Say it as
he would any words. This is how the
companions
spoke. They would speak the words of
the Quran if they were
speaking. However, in recitation, that
is what these rulings are for. These
rulings that are mentioned here. So
Allah says,
"And mention the name of your Lord
and cut yourself off to him." Cut
yourself off to him.
This addition of to him is very
important. Why? Because this word
in the Arabic language, the way that it
was used in the time of Jahyah, the way
that it was used in the culture of the
time when this verse was revealed
was monk monkhood.
A person would be
it means the person would never get
married. Be celibate
is celibacy. That's what it is. And a
comes from the root word.
[Silence]
And so when you would say this person is
that means that this person is a
priest. They don't get married. They're
a celibate.
However, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam prohibited celibacy in Islam.
Islam.
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said, "Allah
has replaced priesthood and celibacy for
us with the
hanifi of Islam which is forgiving
and
not difficult for a person to endure
the previous nations." And the
indicators we have in the Quran with
respect to celibacy is that this was an
innovation
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
never actually prescribe celibacy
upon any prophet or upon any people.
that celibacy
is an innovation that was innovated by
people of the of of Christianity.
Why? Because
of
that
they refer to as John was celibate.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioned this
in the Quran and it's a difference of
opinion whether he was celibate or
whether he was what is meant by alass
that he was very very
very modest.
However, the majority of the scholars of
Tapsi mentioned that when Allah gave
glad tidings
to Zakaria
of Yah, he described him as what?
as a watch. Why they call?
[Silence]
And so celibacy is something that
if it is confirmed that Yahisam was in
fact celibate, this is something
specific to him. But as far as the
prophets and messengers are concerned,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that he
has never sent a messenger except that
Allah says in
that all of the messengers Allah has
designated for them. He has designated
for them
wives and children. All of them and
in some huh
Right? And so the point here is that
celibacy is not part of our religion and
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
when the three men came to say I will
one of them vowed to fast and never
break his fast and the other to pray
every night and never sleep at night and
the third to never marry. He said I pray
and sleep and I fast and I break my fast
and I marry.
So whoever seeks a sunnah a way other
than my way then he is not of me. And so
celibacy is not part of our religion.
So Allah used this word
but he added to it
forchech.
[Silence]
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
"And cut yourself off to him,
not priesthood." Because what does
priesthood do for our relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala? Nothing.
doesn't enhance it doesn't enhance our
lives and it further it further lessens
the amount of good that comes from
marriage to the point that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam mentioned
that marriage is how much of a person's
faith huh half
huh
I can't hear you
[Arabic recitation]
so this narration is that marriage is
part of Islam and the and the reason he
mentions that half of eman is marriage
half of eman any half of a person's dean
and other wordings uses the word din
is that so much of a person's life and
so much of his deeds are going to be
with respect to the rulings between
himself and his wife or wives.
Therefore, on the day of judgment, a
large portion, half
up to half of a person's judgment will
be based on what his im meaning his
dealings in marriage. And this is why
the rulings of marriage are so numerous
in the Quran. Now, notice the wordings
here.
Fat we mentioned is the essence of the
Quran. Correct?
that all of the Quran is an explanation
of surah fat.
Which means that in every single verse
we read of the Quran, we should be able
to find elements of fat in that verse.
That's what that means. Look at the way
that the verses are ordered here. these
three verses. He says,
"And mention the name of your Lord,
and cut yourself off to him,
the Lord of the East and the West,
none is rightfully worshiped but him."
And so place your trust in him and
designate him entirely as your w the one
who is the disposer of your affairs.
He then says
and be patient with your antagonists and
leave their company and refrain from
them and avoid them in the best of ways.
Here is a summarization of fat.
So we start with
Alhamdulillah.
Description of Allah.
[Silence]
And this is how the structure of the
Quran is throughout its entirety. All of
the Quran is an explanation of what?
And all of
is an explanation for which verse?
That is the essence of the Quran. You
alone do we worship and you alone do we
beseech and aid as Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and
[Silence]
Muhammad what what is the evidence that
the
that priesthood or celibacy is an
innovation? Anyone know
what is it?
Uhhuh.
Well, there you go. You got it.
[Silence]
And so it is at the end of that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala described celibacy
as being something which is of the part
of or of the way that was innovated by
some of the followers of Isaam. But you
mentioned something important.
You said it's at the end of but I forget
the verses.
Interestingly,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught
us in our words in speaking about the
Quran. He saidnone of you should ever
say I forgot such and such verse. Rather
he was made to forget. Rather a person
should say
but I was made to forget such and such
verse. Who made him forget such and such
verse? Huh?
Allahan.
Both of you have an evidence, right?
Your evidence is
very good evidence. And your evidence is
what?
very good. So
no,
this is this is the point that we're
making here and that is the context. In
this verse, Allah says we are going to
teach you the Quran and you will not
forget except that which Allah desires
you to forget. This is speaking about
abrogation.
Meaning not that you knew it and then
just forgot it. No, except that what we
choose for you to leave out of the book
after it was revealed. However, this
verse
where
says to Misam, I forgot about the fish
and it's only aan that made me forget.
The scholars say that forgetfulness that
is from a shan
is forgetfulness of something that is
good. Anytime a person forgets something
that Allah commanded him, forgets to
make a salah, forgets to pray, slips his
mind, a verse of the Quran, etc., then
that is the fish of
[Silence]
Allah said about Ysef that when the man
got out, he said, "Hey, you going to get
out? Put in a good word for me. Let your
king know that I'm in here and I'm
innocent. This innocent guy is rotten in
jail." And when he left, what happened?
He Allah says so a shan made him forget
the remembrance of his lord or to remind
his lord.
Remembrance of his lord means it was
ysef that forgot.
To remind his lord means it was the
prisoner who forgot to mention it to his
master. That's the correct meaning that
a shaan couldn't get to Ysef. So what
did he do? He attached himself to the
inter
interceder and made him forget which is
human nature you know. Oh, Yousef,
you're the best guy in the world. And as
soon as he gets out, he forgets him,
right? And he didn't just forget him a
little bit, you know, he completely
forgot him to the point that when the
king came out and said, "Hey, I had this
dream." Anybody knows someone that
explains dreams? Allah says
that he had to really rack his brain for
a long time before he finally remembered
Ysef.
You know how people forget your phone
number when you owe when they owe you
something, but they find it when when
they don't when they need something.
Yeah.
If it's the first of arrest.